you've heard all the scary rumors
surrounding vaccines they cause autism
they contain toxins even that they can
give you the disease that they're trying
to prevent it's misinformation like this
that has caused American vaccination
rates to drop significantly
over the past couple of decades some
people believe their children would be
better off in a world without vaccines
but do they fully grasp what that world
would look like what kind of diseases
would be welcomed back into our lives
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we stopped vaccinations
through the years vaccines have been
successful in reducing the spread of
deadly diseases like measles diphtheria
and rubella to the point where they've
nearly disappeared from America when
people stopped seeing these diseases
some start to wonder why we're still
vaccinating against them well if you
want to see how a so-called controlled
disease can make a comeback just ask the
people of Japan let me paint a picture
for you it's 1974 in Japan and 80% of
people were getting the whooping cough
vaccine with only 393 cases of whooping
cough and 0 related deaths throughout
the whole country that year the Japanese
started to let their guard down by 1979
only 10% of children were being
vaccinated the result was a whopping
13,000 cases that year and 41 related
deaths shocked by the whole ordeal the
Japanese quickly turned back to routine
vaccinations and the disease numbers
dropped once again
people usually see the decision not to
vaccinate as a very personal individual
matter thinking they should have the
right to be able to control what goes
into their child's body sure we get that
but what a lot of people don't
understand is that if everyone made the
same individual decision it would have
catastrophic effects and eventually
spell far more danger for your child the
fewer people who get vaccinated the more
opportunities a disease has to spread
when you decide not to get vaccinated
you're not only accepting the
possibility of contracting a disease
yourself but also the chance of
spreading it to others around you and
playing a part in an epidemic there are
hundreds of thousands of people who
can't get vaccinated do two treatments
for cancer or other conditions and their
safety relies on the rest of us being
vaccinated the next time someone tries
to convince you that vaccines are too
dangerous just let them consider what
our world would look like without
vaccines we'd be transported back to a
world we thought we had overcome where
life for children was especially brutal
in America every year forty eight
thousand people would be hospitalized
with measles and five hundred would die
the chickenpox would cause 10,000
children to be hospitalized and between
70 and 100 would die and hepatitis A and
B would re-emerge as silent epidemics
affecting millions of people these are
just a handful of the old diseases that
would come back to wreak havoc if we all
stopped vaccinations so why stop there
hasn't been a single credible study
linking vaccines to long-term health
conditions in fact the paper that
started the theory that vaccines cause
autism was so discredited that the
author lost his medical license maybe
one day we'll be able to eradicate all
diseases from our planet
but would new challenges just come to
take their place well that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]
that was what if and here's what will
happen if you click like or subscribe
we'll get to make more of the videos you
love educate the masses and maybe even
save the world there's only one way to
find out